wir haben die rede von ursula von der
leyen gehört auch sie geantwortet gab es
denn auch in ihrer entgegnung am schluss
etwas was wir überrascht hat also allen
tatsächlich überraschend gefunden hatte
am ende von freiheit sprach weil ihre
rede war so was von anti freiheitlich
wie es schlimmer nicht sein kann
nein frau von der leyen hat eigentlich
erwartete getan da sie im rechten lager
keine zusätzlichen stimmen einsammeln
kann ist sie ganz weit nach links
gerückt und hat eine rede gehalten die
hätte so auch von herrn thema wann
stammen können das hat schon leicht öko
sozialistische anklänge was sie da
gemacht hat oder auch starke
sozialistische anklänge da passt kein
blatt papier dazwischen zu den ganz
linken wenn sie von sozialisten sprechen
der veranstalter sogar von kommunisten
gesprochen denken sie dass außer ihrer
eigenen wählerschaft jemand das
nachvollziehen kann
also ich glaube schon dass viele viele
menschen sehen wie stark die cdu und
frau von der leyen steht genauso wie
frau merkel ja geradezu exemplarisch
dafür wie stark die cdu im laufe der
letzten 15 jahre von ursprünglich
konservativen positionen abgerückt ist
immer weiter nach links sitzt tief
sozialdemokratische hinein wo sie die
spd pulverisiert haben und das hat frau
von der leyen hier heute auch geliefert
schauen sie sich einmal reden von von
merkel auch von allein übrigens vom
sommer von der jahrtausendwende an als
wären das andere personen da haben die
konservativen positionen vertreten die
sind heute weg das sind linke geworden
und ich glaube dass viele menschen das
sehen